doch sie nicht
in der letzten folge sind beide teams
mit rikschas durch berlin gefahren und
wussten nicht warum team süd zum
beispiel machte einen stopp im ostel
einem hotel mit seltsamer einrichtung
school team nord wusste auch nicht
worauf es bei der tour achten sollte und
plötzlich standen all moderner nicole
und eric im currywurst museum
erst am schluss bekamen beide teams
dieselbe aufgabe sie sollen auf einem
berliner stadtplan die vier stationen
ihre rikscha fahrt einzeichnen
ein glück
team süd ist am alexanderplatz mit der
weltzeituhr gestartet
links das stimmt das macht ein ticket
für team süd
dann hat team süd die designerin
getroffen der lancom
leider falsch denn die drei verfehlen
die adresse auf dem stadtplan
nächste chance für team süd das ostel
das ist unser zweiter punkt
richtig das ging schnell
auch die endstation das brandenburger
tor finden christina jonas und nasser
auf der karte ganz leicht
dem nord ist vom wittenbergplatz aus
gestartet
ja das stimmt das erste ticket
nächster halt für team nord war eine
mensa steht begeisterte kunst hier auch
wichtig
dann kam team nord am currywurst museum
an
das dritte ticket für team nord
und auch das brandenburger tor haben
sich als moderner nicole und eric
gemerkt macht zusammen vier tickets
vor dem reichstag fällt die entscheidung
gewinnt ihn nord oder doch team süd
jetzt werden die gewonnenen tickets aus
dem finale mit den bisherigen tickets
multipliziert
18 punkte für die südgruppe und 36
punkte mit großem vorsprung gewinnen
almudena nicole und eric die freude ist
riesengroß
das ist der endstand im finale kommt ihm
nord auf 36 und team süd auf 18 punkte
für die gewinner geht es sofort weiter
eine limousine bringt team nord zum
flugplatz von hier aus geht es in den
himmel über berlin zu einem rundflug
über die hauptstadt
herzlichen glückwunsch all modena nicole
und eric ihr habt gewonnen
beide teams haben grund zu feiern
sie haben ganz deutschland bereist
schwierige aufgaben gelöst
ungewöhnliche menschen getroffen und das
land von einer anderen seite kennen
gelernt und sie haben jede menge tickets
nach berlin gesammelt
an sich binden
bern
muss ich bin
ich brauche
si